hello and welcome to all things a
creepypasta
or stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce
my name is cz and I will be your server
this episode this episode is brought to
you by ultimate Halloween guide calm
your guide to all things Halloween
Valentine's Day I've always thought we
should just get rid of it and add
another Halloween in its stead however
we're stuck with it it's February and
you clicked on this video so here are
some Valentine's horror stories for you
to sink your teeth into let's dig right
in
number one blind date I'd always found
the concept of a blind date to be
somewhat of a gamble at best it could
lead to a very fun time and who knows
maybe even something more but you run
the risk of a terrible and awkward hour
or more and you never really know what
you might get Tara and I exchanged names
and phone numbers online then decided
only to text each other before the date
in order to preserve the blind aspect of
the encounter I arrived at the
restaurant a few minutes early to find
that she was already there we quickly
got a table and sat down after our
initial introduction one of the first
things that she did was suggest that we
both turn off our phones for the
remainder of the date while I was
surprised at her progressive request I
quickly agreed and powered down my
device I had been on all too many bad
dates where the girl had fallen back and
looking at her phone at the first hint
of an awkward moment I mean I've been
guilty of it too so I figured we may as
well at least attempt to get to know
each other now that we had taken the
time to arrange a date we started with a
small talk the city our job the
obligatory stuff then she started to ask
me weird question questions like have
you ever thought about murdering someone
I told her we all have at some point
right in a joking manner of course she
went on about how planning the perfect
murder in her head was kind of a fun
hobby of hers when she asked me how I
would do it I explained that I kind of
liked the Alfred Hitchcock idea of
stabbing someone with an icicle I wasn't
really sure what to think when I heard
what she said next she told me if you do
it right you've got no reason to make
the evidence disappear of course I was
curious as to where she was going with
it these detectives always look for a
motive
she explained so you simply have to have
no reason to be there no connection to
the person and of course no one
[Music]
well it would be easy to get away with
something like that I did have to wonder
why would you want to kill a random
person she just said that she finds it
kind of exciting it's not that I didn't
realize this conversation was weird
normally I wouldn't find myself talking
about such things with a girl
nonetheless on the first date but for
whatever reason I didn't really mind
discussing it with her I even found it
kind of fun at the end of the date I
picked up the bill and she asked if I
had any plans for the rest of the night
taking the hint I invited her back to my
place and before long we were off upon
arriving home I stepped into the
bathroom to freshen up and brush my
teeth just in case while I was in there
I turned my phone back on to see if I
had missed any messages while I was out
on the date Tara was waiting for me out
in the living room so I tried to be
quick I noticed just one message on my
phone it was from Tara 30 minutes ago
that's odd we hadn't even left the
restaurant thirty minutes ago both of
our phones were off at the time I opened
the message Hey I'm so sorry I didn't
make it
someone slashed my tires I tried calling
but your phone was dead did you still
want to meet up as I tried to comprehend
what I just read
I heard her doing something out in the
kitchen the sound of a drawer opening or
something I was about to go out there
and find out what she was doing
rummaging through my stuff when a wave
of realization hit me with a petrifying
force
no reason to be there no connection to
the person no witnesses I locked the
bathroom door grabbed my phone and
called the number I had for Tara Rayne
one twice every time I started sweating
bullets as I saw her shadow appear in
the crack under the door she had made an
effort to make sure all of her movements
were silent then she just stood outside
the door after what seemed like ages I
heard a voice on the other side of the
line hello hello the woman that picked
up the phone was not the same woman
standing outside my bathroom door not
knowing what else to do I hung up the
phone and began to dial maja
she must have heard me dialing because
she then grabbed the door head one tried
to come into the bathroom as soon as she
realized that it was locked she quickly
moved away from the door I braced myself
for her to barge down the door or
something that's when I heard my front
door open and quickly closed I assumed
that she had left but I didn't dare
leave the safety of blocked bathroom
until the cops had arrived and mocked
down the area of course they found no
trace of the woman I tried to get them
to take down a description of her
appearance but I was told that there was
no case since I had invited her in she
hadn't actually broken any law
as far as I could tell nothing had been
stolen besides without knowing her name
or who she actually was it was unlikely
that they would have found her anyway
eventually I got into contact with the
real Tara and told her about what
happened she was understanding when I
said that I no longer felt comfortable
meeting up for a blind date it's been a
couple of days now since the incident
and I've had an uneasy feeling since
then I've barely gotten any sleep
sometimes I think I hear the sound of my
door handle wiggling like someone is
trying to get in but when I get up and
check on it the sound dissipates she
knew where I live now what was the stop
her from coming back and finishing the
job I tried to tell myself that the
whole thing was a cruel prank that she
was trying to mess with me for her own
entertainment and that she probably just
wanted to scare me or something until
today the since that day I haven't
really had much of an appetite I finally
had the stomach to eat something again
and decided to go to the kitchen and
or something for myself when I found the
kitchen knife put away in the wrong
drawer number two heartbreaker
the stereotypical version of Valentine's
Day has always gotten on my nerves for
one dads never show gay couples and I
tend to get asked out by guys who don't
believe I'm actually gay
this year wasn't different by much I had
to sit through class which I spent
texting my girlfriend Amy going over our
plans for the night our LGBTQ friends
were having a dinner party and we agreed
to go as I was getting up to leave after
class one of the guys walked over to me
I don't know who he is he's one of the
quiet guys who sits in the back he
handed me a heart-shaped note reading
will you be mine I sighed noticing his
friend nervously watching in the back
obviously his friend was asking sorry
but I have a girlfriend I tried to be
nice about it he went back to his friend
and I could feel a cold glare following
me I'm used to guys being rude so I
shrugged it off I went home and got
ready for the night it felt like
something was staring at me from outside
and in the shadows the feeling came back
on and off throughout the night the
party was amazing lots of laughs and
booths everyone was intoxicated
especially Amy as I drove her home there
was a car following us I could feel my
hair standing on end
every time we passed an intersection I
would look back to see if it would turn
it finally turned when we were two
blocks from Amy
I helped her inside and she complained
constantly that it was hot in her
apartment so I opened the window of it
most people would have made out and
proceeded to make a love to their
partner at this point but I have more
dignity than that I gave her a kiss
goodnight and left it was really quiet
on my way home
the feeling of being followed was
finally gone replaced by an uneasy
feeling in my gut maybe the alcohol was
finally kicking in I got back to my dorm
and cracked the window open the night
air felt good on my warm face and
soothed my upset stomach I decided to
take a shot of whiskey before going to
bed as I laid there I thought I could
hear the door rattle it was probably my
imagination the shot I took couldn't
have hit me that hard then again that's
also probably the alcohol I wasn't sure
but I thought I could see the shadow of
beat from underneath the door I could
warn something hit the window but it was
probably just the wind the morning light
hit my eyes and the onset of a hangover
made my head throb the flight smells
blood maybe grown it shouldn't be that
time yes I got up just to make sure
instead of the expected the rug felt wet
under my feet and I discovered a heart
on the floor there was a knife through
it and blood staining my rug my heart
was pounding as the metallic smell
flooded my senses the breath caught in
my throat and my stomach twisted I got
up and rushed to the bathroom the shock
of it all made me sick literally I took
a moment to drink some water after
painfully emptying the contents of my
stomach hoping to ease the sense of
dread knotting it I went back pausing
outside my door it had been a long time
since I last grade and right now I was
praying that it was nothing praying that
it was a delusion I opened the door and
it was still there I couldn't stop
myself from gagging and that's when I
saw the writing wall had blood smeared
on it reading now you can be mine
the police came and they couldn't find
any evidence of forced entry no traces
who did it was left behind I found out
that the heart belonged to a me and it
was determined that they entered through
the window I'm not sure how anyone could
climb three stories from the outside of
the building but now I never leave the
window open at night it's been two years
now and I even moved to a different city
because of rumors that I killed Amy a
new start was supposed to be a good
thing until I found a heart-shaped note
under my door reading your mine number
three
dear Delilah said you're a dear Delilah
these February winds are cold but I
think you will find the winds of change
to be much more comforting over the next
week pay close attention to my
instructions if you do not falter I will
reveal myself and we can spend the final
night together under the stars tomorrow
I want you to look for my letter where
he sends up smoke signals
but they aren't signals for help in fact
he doesn't want them to be seen at all
sincerely Hawkeye February 9 dear
Delilah I know you will find this letter
before he does for you see old habits do
die hard every evening between the hours
of 10:00 and 11:00 p.m. he steps outside
to send up smoke signals every morning
between 10:00 and 11:00 you step outside
to sleep the cigarette busts off the
porch you've done well to look here and
notice because old habits do die hard
you see and I too have a habit a habit
of watching you he may need to fill
himself with poison in order to go on
but I know you have no need for poison
your life the next letter will be
waiting for you in the post office but
only if you demonstrate that you're
willing to kick old habits by skipping
the day of the hour of habit
I'll be watching sincerely hot guy
February 11th
dear Delilah if you are reading this you
have impressed me with your discipline
the day of the hour of habits has passed
and he has not even taken the time to
recognize its significance perhaps it's
time for you to test his discipline
inside this envelope you'll find a thin
but powerful magnet if you want to test
his discipline glue this magnet to the
edge of your door before your
consciousness falls victim to the late
hours if he lacks discipline amid your
innocent slumbers the magnet should slam
the door shut behind him during his
nooblet betrayal for your own safety do
not follow but instead take note of the
time this will correspond to the address
of my next letter you need not leave the
street but only drive west in order to
find it as always I will be watching
sincerely Hawkeye
wre 12 dear Delilah you've done well to
make it this far I understand the
difficulty he has put you through but
you have nearly reached the final night
upon which I will reveal myself to you
under the stars at this point I have had
you on the lookout from my incoming
letters but now I do ask you to do that
which he has not an examined letters
going out you may be surprised to find
him engaging with a less advanced form
of communication however maybe when I
ask you to track a physical envelope to
its destination you'll understand why a
simple text message or email wouldn't
mask his efforts quite like a good
old-fashioned piece of mail inside this
envelope you'll find a microscopic GPS
tracking device the rest is up to you
I'll be watching
sincerely Hawkeye February 13th
dear Delilah I must say I am quite
impressed with your resourcefulness even
I may never have thought of sticking the
tracker on the bottom of the last
postage stamp in the house you've worked
hard to find this destination and your
cleverness will not go in vain
old habits do die hard you see he is
here right now as you read this but you
need not worry as he is passed out as if
she I've made sure of it I've been
watching but before I can review myself
to you I have but one final request
consider the form factor of a cigarette
the inside is filled with disgusting
disposable poison it's wrapped tightly
in a thin sheet of paper then ignited
and burned all the way through in fact a
small cigarette is not much different
than a large cigarette
both are filled with disgusting
disposable poison anything can be used
to wrap a large cigarette bedsheet
blanket pillowcases to be quite honest
it doesn't really matter but what does
matter is that both large and small
cigarettes are burned all the way
through I'm sure you've already found
the content of this envelope this will
be my final letter place all of my
letters inside the large cigarette
before running it through I think you
will find the winds of change to be
comforting tomorrow night I will meet
you at the gravesite and reveal myself
to you then we can spend the final night
together under the stars
sincerely Hawkeye thanks for listening
to all dente creepypasta your total
comes out to two dollars and fourteen
cents but if you like this video right
now I'll waive that fee and give you
everything you just listen to absolutely
free remember to subscribe to seize
these world for new Horrors every other
week ring that death bell for
notifications I'll see you in the next
one
assuming we both survive
[Music]